tengo el número 235 y podemos pensar en
él como dos centenas tenemos un dos en
el lugar de las centenas dos centenas
tres decenas tenemos un 13 en el lugar
de las decenas así que tres decenas y
cinco unidades
tenemos un cinco en el lugar de las
unidades y por aquí
de hecho la dibuje con todas estas cajas
éstas son 235 cajas tienes dos grupos de
100 cajas estas son dos centenas luego
tenemos tres decenas uno dos tres y
luego tenemos cinco unidades
ahora probemos algunas cosas
interesantes aquí
qué pasa si quisiera sumar sumar 10 aquí
bueno sumando 10 solo estamos sumando
una
no solo estamos sumando una decena si
sumás una decena que es lo que pasará
aquí tengo que sumar una decena más
tengo que sumar esta decena como se
vería a eso bueno la siguiente decena se
verá así déjame ver si puedo dibujar
rápido tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y 10 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y 10 así que solo
agregue una decena con que nos deja eso
bueno si tenía 3 decenas y tengo una
decena más ahora ahora tendré cuatro
decenas ahora tendré 4
más
aún tendré 5 unidades 5 unidades aún
tendré 5 unidades
no estoy sumando ninguna unidad a y aún
y aún tendré dos centenas no estoy
sumando ninguna centena y así que aún
tendré dos sen
más
dos centenas ahora serán dos centenas
más cuatro decenas más cinco unidades
dos centenas más cuatro decenas más
cinco unidades y cuántos será eso bueno
cinco unidades 245 hagamos uno más en
lugar de sumar una decena sumamos una
centena hagamos eso veamos si puedo
limpiar todo esto
así
que en lugar de sumar 10 sumamos una
centena aquí sumar más sumamos una
centena unam déjame de hecho hacerla en
amarillo y azul estoy sumando una
centena 0 decenas y 0 unidades
esencialmente solo sumó una centena así
que esto va a ser igual a más una
centena así que más una centena eso
cuánto me dará déjame dibujarlo por aquí
déjame copiar y pegar tenía dos centenas
antes pero ahora voy a sumar una centena
déjame sólo copiar eso y pegarlo
así que ahora cuántas centenas tengo
cuántas centenas tengo ahora ahora tengo
123 centenas tengo tres centenas por
aquí tenía dos centenas estoy sumando
una centena más por aquí
por lo que ahora tengo tres centenas por
aquí puedo decir que ahora tengo tres
más
ahora el número de escenas ha cambiado
no tuve tres decenas antes y no estoy
sumando decenas esta vez así que aún
tendré tres decenas y tuve cinco
unidades antes y no estoy sumando más
unidades así que aún tengo cinco
unidades así que tengo 335 que es lo
mismo que tres centenas más tres decenas
más cinco unidades más cinco y me da 10